this comes after another night of
violent protests over the death of
George Floyd demonstrations have erupted
across the country including here in Las
Vegas after the Minneapolis man died in
police custody earlier tonight
representatives of our community held a
press conference promoting unity and
peace
Kate Houston joins us live now from
metro headquarters with more on their
message for tonight Kate yes Sasha
that's right sheriff Lombardo mayor
Goodman and local faith leaders all had
the same message tonight they were
calling for tonight's protest to be
peaceful now there were also members
from the multicultural Advisory Council
they were here to talk about the
conversations and expectations between
community members and Las Vegas police
officers they're hoping that these words
will encourage everyone protesting
tonight to be peaceful not turning a
blind eye to any of their voices and
their concerns what has occurred in the
past what I want people to do is move
forward and what I want people to do
today is protest practice your First
Amendment rights within the limits of
the law we're all flawed we know we have
to make it better we work at it but
every member of our law enforcement
every member of each community black
yellow tan any color any faith any any
belief in anything we are a family of
one people and we work every day because
we believe in love we want to see that
our community is safe that this is a
time that we send a clear message what
to expect to the parents there's a lot
of young people many of us our parents
and grandparents we have high schoolers
and young kids that are looking at the
news and it looks exciting and fun to go
out and see what's happening out in the
streets and send a message but tonight
is not the time and it's not the right
way it is dangerous it's okay to March
we have that right to March
but to describe another man's property
is wrong and we cannot stoop that low
so if you want a change in your
community you have to become that change
these are all incredibly powerful words
ahead of tonight's protest at container
park now I do want to share as well
pastor Troy Martinez says that he does
not want any violence or agitators from
outside groups he does not want this to
infringe on anything that these peaceful
protesters are trying to accomplish
tonight he does not want what happened
in Minneapolis to happen here in Las
Vegas reporting live from the Las Vegas
metropolitan Police Department Keith
Houston 8 News now